clear the line clear the
line okay you're double
pivoting keep going I can talk and you
can
move so the arm you got to turn the
wrist the right way to make the elbow a
lever
he okay you can't do those pins in Gaza
he can get up he can get up you have to
do a actual pin change
rolls don't push him please
he same thing it turned a a little bit
the wrong way you got some Flex in that
elbow got to lock his
body get more Yin
[Music]
yield
there's that double pivot
again you just shoving them backwards
you need the yin
yields you have to make you have for
that you need to make a tighter turn
inside that otherwise you're just
accelerating accelerating him
outward not
quite this is a small turn inside
no you're not just going
around I'm not here then I like that
come
around there is going to be centrifical
energy but as your bance starts to go I
turn it
tighter not down you're falling on your
own there we
go that's it do you feel that okay
you're going like
this you can walk out of that and you're
supposed to as
you should
out same technique
discussed
did you feel your base compromised is
you're pushing on
him
whoops got to get out of the way can't
put him where you
are got you got to do a pin and G
Wasa
so you're not letting them
through
this is what I mean by
AIT not
that even if you do a vers
can't shove in they have to be
internally
soft I can't go
forward but it's
internally
say you get caught
like again
right be in the body but
internally not here in the body he
stands up and let him stand
up
other teches okay more
[Music]
yielding you're you're in his arms
you're in his
arms even even that's in his AR in his
arms in his arm
[Music]
again what I what I mean is in his
arm can you hold on
please
cut pulling basically their skin sleeve
and eventually PS you down you
understand so uh that's why we go uh if
you
pull see it doesn't
matter it's not that I
am getting out of the way that's only in
your arm only in your arm here like that
and you can see the kind of
slinking it's like it has to be whip l
you see but here your arm is going to be
one you see that move with you with
you there's no lag time between the arm
and the center the movement goes
Center Center so even when I yield it's
not that I pull your skin sleeve the
movement you you feel it is moving
you
so even here it's not that I get out of
the way the the movement is going to be
moving your
body not your arm eventually pulls your
body the
movement is
moving and here not AR swinging and IA
here this moves your
body or bypass the arm go right to the
body ignore
the not not both okay start again